So let's
turn to the
double murder trial of former lawyer
Alex Murdaugh.
He is accused,
as you know, of killing his wife
and his son.
Will, during
cross-examination yesterday
in court
of a special agent, Murdaugh's
defense attorney
floated the theory
that two shooters
could have committed the murders
Randi Kaye is live in Walterboro
South Carolina.
I was surprised to
seeing this line of questioning,
but I think the answer
that Harpootlian finally got,
too, was interesting.
Tell us more
Yeah, it sure was, Poppy.
This agent basically said,
you know what,
just because two weapons
were used doesn't
mean that there had to be two sh
That one person could have handl
both of those weapons.
And of course, the prosecution i
that person is Alec Murdaugh.
We also got a look inside his gu
at the home.
And we got to look at a second i
that he gave investigators just
after the murder.
They seem to be trying to test
his consistency in the details.
Here's a look
because
he's so
nice.
A girl, a wonderful wife.
She was a great mom,
an emotional
Alec Murdoch
in his second interview
with investigators
following the murders of his wif
and son.
First, he cries about his wife,
Maggie Murdoch.
Then at one point,
he says this about his youngest
son, Paul.
So bad, so bad.
The interview with SLED,
the South
Carolina Law Enforcement
Division, took place on June 10t
20, 21, three days after the mur
investigators asked
Alec to walk them through what h
that day.
Alec said he left work early
and he and Paul went target
shooting on their hunting proper
Do you mean what gun? Yeah.
A 22 of Magnum.
That 22 Magnum
he says they used
is not one of the weapons
used in the murders.
Maggie was shot
with a rifle
and Paul was killed with a shotg
Alec also told investigators
he wasn't at the kennels
earlier in the night.
I know that Maggie went to the k
I don't
know exactly where Paul went,
but he left her house, too.
What did you do when?
Once, Maggie, you pull up?
I stayed in the house.
Keep in mind,
Alec Murdoch is heard
on a recording on his son
Paul's phone at 8:45 p.m.,
and that was recorded at the ken
He told investigators
twice now in separate interviews
He didn't go to the kennels
until he found their bodies.
Earlier, his defense attorney
floated the idea that two guns c
two shooters.
Is it a possibility
that there are two shooters
based on the data you collected?
It just indicated
to me.
But prosecutors were quick to po
one person could have used two g
Another witness for the state's
special agent,
Jeffrey Croft, testified about t
for the first time.
It shows investigators
the day after the murders
searching parts of the Murdoch h
including this gun room outside
they found spent shell casings
there
They've been here a lot.
About 300
later, Special Agent Croft
walked the jury
through a series of missed calls
and text messages to Paul Murdoc
the night of the murders.
Can you tell the jury the times
starting at the bottom
that he's trying to call Paul Mu
without an answer at 9:29 p.m.
there's a one second outgoing ca
at 9:42 p.m.
And at 9:57 p.m.,
there's a four second outgoing c
when the caller, a friend,
couldn't reach Paul.
The special agent said
he texted Maggie Murdoch.
What does he say?
Tell Paul to call me.
Neither Paul or Maggie ever resp
So this morning, Poppy,
the question, of course, is were
and Maggie already dead
when that friend
was trying to reach them by phon
We know from the prosecution
in that Paul's
phone stopped
any type of activity at 8:49 p.m
Maggie's phone
stopped all activity at 8:54 p.m
that night.
So it does seem that they were d
when all that phone activity did
stop Poppy.
Randi Kaye,
thank you very much for the repo